the only political group on the right
that is winning right now is moms it's
not the GOP Congressman it's certainly
not the GOP Senators those losers are
selling our whole political order down
the river as they made perfectly clear
yesterday we'll get to that in just a
minute
those guys are useless no the only
political group on the right right now
that is scoring wins is moms at school
boards listen to this the Berkeley
County School District in South Carolina
just swore in its new school board
members who were elected last week six
of whom were endorsed by the
conservative group moms for Liberty
within two hours
the new members replaced the board
chairman with a solid conservative fired
the district's woke superintendent fired
the district's woke lawyer banned
critical race Theory from the curricula
and set up a committee to round up all
the idiotic and pornographic books from
the school libraries and ban them
two hours imagine what they could do in
two weeks two months two years two
decades
that's Vision that's courage that is the
right way to wield political power
I only want to know two things one when
can we send these moms for Liberty
candidates to Washington and two where
can I donate I'm Michael knows this the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Benjamin
waddle who says this was a tremendously
intelligent and remarkably easy to watch
members block thank you for bringing on
such captivating panelists oh yeah
Benjamin do you enjoy when I bring
supermodels on the member block if
you're not a daily wire plus member and
you're not getting that member block you
really missed a great one yesterday
where we debated uh why hot women like
Pete Davidson and actually my real
favorite comment from yesterday was not
from YouTube it was from the members
block I forget who said it but someone
said that Pete Davidson looks like a wet
cigarette and that really sounded true
to me that really struck a chord so you
got to join you got to become a member
we've got great members block content
coming up today as we do every single
day and then it just gives you something
to talk about with your friends and your
family and when you want to talk to them
you got to check out pure talk right now
head on over to puretalk.com enter code
Knowles there is no reason to pay
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile over 80 dollars
per month for wireless Services when you
can get the same service on the same
network of pure talk for half the price
with pure talk you can get talk text and
data that is just as fast for just
thirty dollars per month those other
guys are making you pay for thousands of
retail stores that you don't go to perks
that you don't use and massive profits
to keep their shareholders happy Pure
Talk on the other hand wants to keep you
happy which is why they've invested in a
us-based customer service team it's also
why they give you so many more data
options why would they charge you for
data that you don't need I switched to
Pure Talk I love it
I I love supporting veteran-owned
us-based companies that have our best
interests at heart takes less than 10
minutes to make the switch and you can
save a ton of money as I am saving a ton
of money go to puretalk.com enter code
Knowles to save 50 off your first month
that is puretalk.com promo code knows
for 50 off your first month
absolutely phenomenal stuff from the
moms for Liberty and the Berkeley County
School District in South Carolina but
you're seeing this around the country
there was another mother she just showed
up to a school board meeting in Texas
she showed up to this school board
meeting and she just read from a book
that is in the school library uh
listener discretion advised if your kids
are listening right now maybe just skip
ahead you know 30 seconds or a minute uh
listen to the way that the board reacts
to the book that is in the school
library
but we fill our minds with matters
consider that as I read this from a
current library book
this one couple stumbled into my room
and asked if they could use the room
anyway with me still in it they closed
the door and started kissing after a few
minutes the boy's hand went up the
girl's shirt and she started protesting
pretty soon he took off her bra and
started to kiss her breasts and then he
put his hand down her pants and she
started moaning he reached to take off
her pants but she started crying really
hard so he reached for his own he pulled
his pants and underwear down to his
knees please Dave no but the boy just
talked stuff to her about how good she
looked and she grabbed with her hands
and started moving it the boy pushed the
girl's head down and she started to kiss
his
she was still crying finally she stopped
crying because he put his face in her
mouth and I don't think you can cry in
that position I ask you why this book
Thank you survived two attempts out
thank you so much and there is a there's
a child in our boardroom so I'd like for
you to please stop reading that
did you see the child
okay
then your your time is up thank you
so they cut off her microphone so you
can't hear her response but you can hear
the people laughing in the audience she
says excuse me ma'am there's a child
here you need to stop reading from the
books in our school library there's a
child here you're in the audience say
yeah right that's the point the mother's
there she goes no I didn't see the child
but that's the point what are you
talking about ma'am that's very
pornographic and obscene and not
appropriate for children stop reading
the books that we put in our libraries
out loud
don't read the books that we're teaching
your kids
no the real reason that the school board
doesn't want that mother to read the
book is not because a child might hear
it it's because the other parents might
hear it and the other parents might
realize what insane radicals are running
the schools so this is good stuff it's
good when the parents come out there and
expose this stuff
it's good when the handful of people in
the conservative media who will break
through that kind of mainstream
gatekeeper and actually tell you what's
really going on it's good when that
happens to expose these things
that can't be the end of the story
the end of the story cannot be look at
how crazy the left is wow they're
hypocrites
they those guys man they're bad they say
that they're good but they're really bad
that can't be the end of the story the
end of the story has to be yeah it's bad
we've exposed the problem we see the
problem
after that diagnosis we need to take
action okay
the the end of the story has to be
we elect new school board members and
they immediately fly into action
fire the crazy teachers fire the
superintendent fire the chairman of the
school board kick all of them out and
start Banning these pornographic books
from schools
you have to do stuff
and the libs aren't going to like that
and the libs are going to try to try to
convince the conservatives that actually
it's not very conservative to actually
do anything this is what happened for
the past 20 or so years on the right is
that the libs convinced the the right to
adopt this kind of weird libertarian
kind of shallow ethos where the
conservatives convinced themselves that
doing anything in politics is somehow
immoral or unprincipled well it would be
you know if we do anything
then that would make us no different
from the left the left you see puts a
bunch of weird porn in schools but if we
take the weird porn out of schools we're
no different than the left no we're
totally different that's the opposite
actually you're saying if we wield
political power we're no different from
the left no I guess we would be
we would be similar to the left in that
we would be actually participating in
politics
but we would be the opposite of the left
because we would be doing the opposite
things they want to make our country
worse we want to make our country better
they want a pedal falsehood we want to
Peddle the truth we want to reveal the
truth and inculcate the truth in the
minds especially of young children this
is why education has become such a flash
point
because for years the conservatives we
threw up our hands we were treated from
the Public Square we said well you know
I don't I you do you but I don't I'm not
a hero okay I'm just going to go off to
my own little island and that's not
going to work because that just gives
the political space all over to the left
so now conservatives have woken up
this occurred during the Trump years
this was really one of the consequences
of the new trumpian approach to politics
which is not really new at all
it's actually a reversion to the old
right it's a reversion to how
conservatives rightly understood
politics to be until about 20 25 years
ago
and and the moms started showing up to
the school boards
and then the moms started electing
people
and then the moms are the reason why
Glenn Younkin became the Republican
governor of Virginia
and the moms are the reason why Rhonda
Santos has been so successful in Florida
and what is one one of Ron desantis's
greatest pieces of legislation he's
passed it's the stop woke Act
the stop woke act which says no we are
going to have standards we are going to
have Norms we're going to give parents
rights and education
we're not going to let these radicals
just poison the minds of children
and so now
the libs are relying not on the people
the people love the stopwoke act the
people hate it when the radicals try to
poison our kids brains with weird race
stuff and transgenderism and all the
rest of it so now the left is relying on
the judges and the judge the judges are
trying to stop the parents from having a
say over their kids education this is
what a chief U.S District Judge Mark
Walker just said as he issued a
preliminary injunction to stop the stop
woke Act
stop work by the way refers to stop
wrongs to our kids and employees
politicians love a good initialism they
do or a good acronym so uh this is what
the judge had to say about it the judge
says that lacking explicit standards to
circumscribe enforcement of objectivity
defendants can weaponize this term to
further discredit the eight Concepts in
the marketplace of ideas which now
permits endorsement of only one side of
the debate accordingly because this
objectivity savings Clause commands the
entire statute the IFA this is another
way to refer to the stopwoke act as the
individual Freedom Act is impermissibly
vague on its face in violation of the
due process clause of the 14th Amendment
let me translate that gobbledygook into
English for you
the judge is saying that by uh by
kicking
radicalism and transgenderism and
critical race Theory and all this
nonsense out of our schools that we're
threatening the free Marketplace of
ideas
then we'll only have one side of the
debates now two problems with this one
would you describe classrooms today as a
free Marketplace of ideas where all
sides are heard and well represented
or would you describe it as an
ideological Echo chamber where only
leftism thrives
obviously it's the latter the idea that
there is a free Marketplace of ideas in
our classrooms today is completely
Preposterous I I don't think I need to
explain myself you've all seen the
videos of me and other people going to
classrooms all around the country you've
been to school yourself your kids have
been to school you understand what this
means but second of all
even if there were such a thing as a
free Marketplace of ideas in classrooms
there really shouldn't be certainly not
in elementary schools or middle schools
do you really believe a fourth grade
classroom is supposed to be a free
Marketplace of ideas where new
scientific discoveries are being made of
course not it's a place to learn your
ABCs and two plus two equals four and
boys are boys and girls are girls the
problem is that these days the kids in
the schools are learning the two plus
two equals five and the little Johnny
actually can be little Jane just don't
tell your parents head on down to the
guidance counselor and he's going to
give you some puberty blockers that's
what's happening
there of course there's no free
Marketplace of ideas
in Early Education at the very least
there is coercion to learn a certain set
of facts and if you get those facts
wrong on your test you're going to get a
bad grade and flunk out that's what it
really is
the even the justification for a free
Marketplace of ideas is that well that
will allow new discoveries to be made
and Advance the human race it's a
dubious Prospect in many in many cases
but let's say even that that were true
even if it were true that's not
happening in third grade okay it's just
complete nonsense from the federal judge
who is threatened
is feeling threatened that leftism is
not going to have its absolute
establishment in the elementary schools
and throughout education
it's really not good okay because if you
want to have a good education if you
want to cultivate the very best in you
then you've got to you've got to put
good stuff in you've got to get good
fuel okay you've got to get good facts
you've got to get good literature you've
got to get good philosophy that is going
to fuel your mind now when you want to
fuel a turkey fryer this Thanksgiving
you got to get a good propane tank you
got to check out cinch right now go to
cinch.com use promo code Knowles I love
Thanksgiving one of the real highlights
of Thanksgiving is when people bust out
that turkey fryer right but before you
bust out that turkey fryer you got to
call cinch and get your propane tank
exchanged cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule there is no
long-term commitment or subscription
required plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to be home to
receive the delivery you can track the
order on the Cinch app from anywhere are
you looking to exchange a tank cinch
handles that whole process for you so
you don't have to go to the hardware
store or the gas station you can
exchange any brand of tank as long as it
is standard Grill size you choose your
delivery date and cinch handles the rest
it is so so easy
go to cinch.com or download their app to
order new customers can get their first
tank exchange for just ten dollars with
promo code nulls kwles go to cinch.com
or download the Cinch app and use promo
code nulls to get your first tank
exchange for just ten dollars that is c
y n c h.com promo code nulls this is a
limited time offer you must live within
a cinched service area to redeem it at
cinch.com
offer for details federal judge in
Florida stopping Ron desantis's stop
woke act by claiming it threatens the
free Marketplace of ideas that doesn't
exist but also saying this he says one
thing is crystal clear
both robust intellectual inquiry and
democracy require light to thrive our
professors are critical to a healthy
democracy and the state of Florida's
decision to choose which viewpoints are
worthy of Illumination and which must
remain in the shadows has implications
for us all if our Priests of democracy
are not allowed to shed light on
challenging ideas then democracy will
die in darkness this is a federal judge
writing this nonsense but the First
Amendment does not permit the State of
Florida to muzzle its University
professors impose its own Orthodoxy on
viewpoints of viewpoints and cast us all
into the dark
hold on
the First Amendment
does not permit the State of Florida to
impose its own Orthodoxy of viewpoints
on the
Priests of democracy which is how the
judge describes the professors you see
do you see the problem there
the judge is saying
that the the people of Florida the
people as represented by the state
have no right
to have their own moral views
they have no right to impose that
Orthodoxy into the classroom and by
impose it means set the standards for
the community that that is going to be
taught to the children
instead the priests of democracy have
that exclusive right to impose their
Orthodoxy so just saying the people
don't have the right to Orthodoxy to
their beliefs it's it's the leftists
they're the only ones with the right to
their Orthodoxy which is evil and wrong
I just any time someone tells you
leftism is not a religion please quote
them judge Walker's opinion on the stop
woke act he is admitting it is a
religion the professors or the priests
of that religion he then goes on to
quote a a slogan from a left-wing
newspaper The Washington Post
democracy will die in darkness I mean
this is really sad stuff
really sad stuff that a federal judge
has the intellect and education that
stops at the level of popular newspaper
slogans really pathetic how far our
country has fallen but an important
reminder
that this is a religious battle and I
know there's a lot of conservatives who
say I'm not all that religious I'm sort
of agnostic oh come on enough with the
religion talk
I didn't I didn't start the religion
talk okay
the religion talk is all around politics
because all human conflict is
theological it's the left that is
imposing the religion talk
the religion of leftism
the priests of which are the professors
in the universities and the teachers and
all the rest of the apparatchics in this
hierarchy of the Church of leftism
and the only way to fight that bad
religion is with good religion nature
abhor is a vacuum man is fundamentally a
religious being okay we have ultimate
questions that we have to answer that
inevitably we are going to Grapple with
what is death what is judgment is there
a heaven is there a hell what am I for
what is the good life who made me what
is what is life what is those are
questions that will not be answered by
history
or natural science or I don't know
chemistry they can't be answered by
those things those are questions that
ultimately have to be answered by
religion and they will either be
answered by false religion like the
religion of Judge Walker here or by True
Religion by Christianity by the religion
that animates and built our entire
civilization and you've got to pick a
side if you stand in the middle of the
road you will be run over by a truck
you're either with God or against God Is
What It ultimately comes down to okay
and I think what the greatest trick the
devil ever played is pretending that he
doesn't exist and for a long time
the leftists have pretended that they're
just secular you know they're just
secular they're they don't have this
religion stuff that's all Hui from the
Dark Ages or whatever no they're
admitting it they're admitting that they
have a religion so you're either going
to be part of their religion or you're
going to be part of True Religion I
advise you to choose wisely so meanwhile
as the as the libs awful sort of
religion of leftism takes over
unfortunately
I'm sorry to say many so-called
conservatives are going along with it
this was so pathetic yesterday
Democrats in Congress
just proposed
a a further destruction of the family
the family has been very weakened
it's been weakened for 60 years now the
the left has done everything it can to
weaken the family
now they're trying to deal a death blow
and that would be through something they
euphemistically call the respect for
Marriage Act
the respect for Marriage Act would
codify the obergefell decision which
invents a new definition of marriage
completely contrary to the actual
definition of marriage that has
prevailed everywhere for all of human
history and it would codify it and go
further it would prohibit businesses
from following their conscience from
being Christian or Jewish or Muslim
though as a as a practical matter they
will only enforce this against
Christians they this sort of law would
make Jack Phillips and masterpiece cake
shop illegal if you don't want to
participate in a gay wedding that that
will be illegal now if you're a business
it's a radical radical redefinition of
the family which is the fundamental unit
of society
so I'm not surprised that the libs
peddle this they hate the family they
hate society and they want to destroy
the country
but I am disgusted that conservatives
would go along with it and a dozen of
them did these are the Senators who went
along with it there were a bunch of
congressmen in the house from this past
a while ago and then the Senators
yesterday went along with it to to
advance this legislation beyond the
filibuster which puts it on a fast track
to being passed Roy blunt
Richard Burr so Roy blunt from Missouri
Richard burr from North Carolina Shelly
capito from West Virginia Susan Collins
from Maine Joni Ernst from Iowa Cynthia
Lumis from Wyoming it's too bad I
actually like her but horrible horrible
judgment here Lisa murkowski from Alaska
Rob Portman from Ohio and of course Mitt
Romney from Utah
absolutely pathetic so these people
these conservatives
can't conserve anything they can't
conserve anything we joke about how all
these conservatives they can't even
conserve the women's bathroom they can't
conserve anything they can't conserve
the basic unit of society they just are
Democrats they just are liberals
and they're radical liberals they're
they're liberals further to the left of
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton in
2011. okay that's how radical they are
really really pathetic What is marriage
I get a lot of people just don't
understand this anymore marriage is the
lifelong communion of a husband and his
wife
for the good of the spouses and for the
sake of the generation and education of
children that's what marriage is
why can't two people who love each other
just get married
well they can but not all love is the
same and not all unions are the same I
love my grandmother I'm not going to
marry my grandmother
I love my friends I'm not going to marry
my friends
I love my co-workers I'm not going to
marry my co-workers
What is marriage marriage cannot be
redefined because marriage is not merely
a social construct or a sort of
political contrivance marriage is a
natural institution this is defined by
Aristotle defined by Saint Thomas
Aquinas as the natural state of man man
is a paring creature we are canubial
creatures even more than political
creatures and we are drawn to propagate
the species with our spouse and to help
one another
that's what marriage is so you cannot
redefine sexual difference is at the
very heart of marriage if you don't get
that
you don't get anything
as a conservative if you cannot conserve
the natural Institution
maybe one of the most fundamental
aspects of human nature
you can't conserve
anything
so why did these people vote for it why
did they vote for it
I suspect some because they're just
absolute disgraceful sellouts like Mitt
Romney but some
because they think well it's a lost
cause
it's a lost cause people support the
redefinition of marriage now so Michael
give up it's a lost cause that's what
they told us about abortion for 49 years
it's a lost cause Give It Up
oh come on it's a lost cause
and then it wasn't a lost cause I've got
some thoughts on lost causes all right
but when you want to protect yourself
when things are looking really bad you
got to check out gold you got to check
out Birch gold right now text Knowles to
98 98 98 inflation continues to bedevil
our economy the daily wire reports that
in less than two years inflation has
soared from 1.4 percent to 8.6 percent
as of May 2022 the price of gas was up
nearly 49 price of meat poultry fish up
14.2 percent price of used cars up 16
the current administration's
irresponsible spending patterns
including Biden's 1.9 trillion dollar
rescue plan continue to exacerbate the
problem
now is not the time to have all your
money tied up in the stock market don't
let your savings wither away hedge
against inflation with gold from Birch
gold right now text Knowles kwles to 98
98 98 and Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on protecting your savings
with gold Birch gold is giving out a
free gold bar with any Purchase made by
December 22nd but you must submit your
claim by Black Friday with almost 20
years of experience in converting IRAs
and 401ks into precious metals IRAs
Birch gold can help you too don't sit
around while the fed devalues your
hard-earned money text Knowles kwles to
98 98 98 and learn how you can convert
at least part of your savings into a
precious metals Ira if you place an
order by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar text Knowles
kwles to 9898-98
one of the great Twitter people d e at
TK Dylan made a great point he said you
got to talk about this on the show it's
a quote from T.S Eliot on lost causes
and T.S Eliot writes
if we take the widest and wisest view of
a cause there is no such thing as a lost
cause because there is no such thing as
a gained cause we fight for lost causes
because we know that our defeat and
dismay may be the preface to our
successor's Victory though that Victory
itself will be temporary we fight rather
to keep something alive than in the
expectation that anything will Triumph
of course there's no such thing as a
lost cause
we know this because when we win
something we have to fight like hell to
preserve it because we know that that
thing that we won is on the brink of
Decay at any given moment
on the brink of collapse
so if there are no one causes there are
no lost causes people say well move on
who cares it's just the definition of
marriage
just the definite that's kind of
everything isn't it
why won't you just give this up and move
on because if we cannot preserve the
fundamental political institution
we can't we can't conserve anything at
all and the tax thing doesn't matter
immigration doesn't matter
I mean
kind of like nothing matters if you
fundamentally reorder your Society down
to that Atomic level
okay
then then it's just a matter of time
do not do that
I think even for the conservatives who
say well who cares about marriage I'm
not with you on this one Michael you
crazy religious people you crazy
Christians
and Jews and Muslims and everybody for
all and virtuous pagans and everybody
for all of history
I just come on I don't see it ask
yourself why don't you get it
have a little bit of humility perhaps
and ask yourself why is it that
statistically every single person for
all of history and 100 of these smart
people through all of history have
thought that marriage means one thing
until
seven or so years ago
including the leftists until about 11
years ago
and now
I think that all those people were wrong
why why is it and when people say I just
don't understand the issue of marriage
well right that's the problem and maybe
have a little humility
and do not
take on a stance on this issue do not
destroy marriage until you understand
why people thought the way they thought
about it in the first place
it's just chesterton's fence before you
you walk into the middle of field you
see a fence fence appears to have no
purpose
and you say okay I'm going to tear down
that fence because I don't know what
it's there for you've got it you've got
to take a pause and say hold on it is
not until I figure out what it is
therefore that I will tear it down
because I don't I I don't want to go
into this thing ignorantly and
potentially destroy society which is
what the people have done now a little
bit of good news better news coming out
of the House of Representatives Nancy
Pelosi has just lost her gavel and with
great confidence in our caucus I will
not seek reelection through Democratic
Leadership in the next Congress
Nancy Pelosi is out I love that was a
daily wire video of a superposition of
uh Nancy Pelosi at a bar and everything
well seeing Nancy she's gone so she's no
longer going to be the speaker of the
house because she's not in the majority
anymore and she is not going to run for
House minority leader which means
effectively she'll keep her seat in the
House of Representatives but Nancy
Pelosi is done
she is done as a major force in American
politics she held on for a very long
time now she is done now the Republicans
are taking over what are the Republicans
going to do well we've got an
announcement from representative James
Comer republican from Kentucky who says
they are going to waste no time
getting to investigate Hunter and Joe
Biden
this is an investigation of Joe Biden
the president of the United States and
why he lied to the American people about
his knowledge and participation in his
family's international business schemes
National Security interests require the
Committee conduct investigation and we
will pursue all avenues avenues that
have long been ignored committee
Republicans have uncovered evidence of
federal crimes committed by and to the
benefit of members of the president's
family these include
conspiracy or defrauding the United
States
wire fraud conspiracy to commit wire
fraud violation of the foreign agent's
registration act violations of the
Foreign Corrupt Practices Act violations
of the trafficking victims protection
act tax evasion money laundering and
conspiracy to commit money laundering
the Biden family's business dealings
implicate a wide range of criminality
from Human Trafficking to potential
violations of the constitution in the
118th Congress this committee will
evaluate the status of Joe Biden's
relationship with his family's foreign
partners and whether he is a president
who is compromised or swayed by Foreign
dollars and influence I want to be clear
this is an investigation of Joe Biden
okay so I like the way he frames this he
says this is not just an investigation
of Hunter Biden who nobody really cares
about but it's an investigation of Joe
Biden right we see on Hunter Biden's
laptop he says 10 goes to the big guy so
is Hunter just off there on his own
making a bunch of money without any
knowledge of his father trading on his
father's name getting his father to
potentially make some phone calls
or is this corruption that implicates
Joe
I like it I think it's important to
investigate Hunter Biden I think it's
important to investigate Anthony fauci I
think it's even though fact sheet now is
quitting so that he hopefully doesn't
get investigated in his views I hope he
still does
we need to do all of this
however
I go back to those moms for
liberty-backed candidates at the school
board we need results
okay very often house panels don't do
anything there's lots and lots of
investigation and it amounts to nothing
when the Democrats do it there's the
January 6 investigation that's not going
to do anything
and then there's the Benghazi
investigation didn't do very much and on
and on and on
we need results
okay
if this investigation is not going to
end in
Joe Biden or people very close to him in
orange jumpsuits
then just don't do it then spend your
time on other stuff it's it's very
frustrating to me that we spend a ton of
money sending people to Washington DC as
conservatives and they conserve
basically nothing and as we saw this
week with the Republicans in the Senate
they don't they haven't they can't
conserve even the basic fundamental
political unit
and then we spend very little money
sending women to school boards and then
they actually get things done that
actually matter in Americans lives and
shape the minds of the Next Generation
so when I'm looking at those two things
I'm thinking okay maybe I'm not going to
write as many checks to the republicans
in Congress who don't do anything anyway
and I I am going to start writing my
checks to the school board candidates
who are actually getting things done we
need
results
you know cyber week is almost upon us
and you are in luck okay because we have
just launched the all-new daily wire
plus shop pick up something worth
keeping there is a sweet baby album
t-shirt there is the Johnny The Walrus
book and plushie bundle there is the
daily wire left this year's tumbler
there's the dog bowl bundle and so much
more the new daily wear plus shop is
your chance to defund woke everything
this holiday season by heading to
dailywire.com shop today probably the
most important things you can get in the
shop speechless controlling words
controlling Minds my number one National
best-selling book with words and then
also really important stocking stuffer
for your liberal family and friends
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide another number one
National best-selling book at least on
Amazon the lists didn't want to list it
I endorsed by President Donald Trump so
make sure you uh shop there throughout
cyber week
also Jeremy's razors may have started as
the best joke we ever told now it is
more real than ever in his quest to earn
your business from web companies to hate
your guts the god king turned a single
glorious razor into a triumphant new
line of men's products nourishing
shampoo conditioner charcoal body wash
luxurious beard kit and the new
Precision 5 razor with flip back trimmer
yes they're all very real and very
spectacular if you're ready to get a
great shave or exfoliating wash from a
company that will never bow down to the
web mob go to jeremy'srazers.com and
Shop the brand new line of products now
that's Jeremy's razors.com today
finally finally
we have arrived
at my favorite time of the week when I
get to hear from you in the mailbag
mailbag is sponsored by puretalk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code Knowles to get 50 off your first
month take it away with voicemail bag
hi Michael I just found out that I am uh
having a boy I'm pregnant with my first
child and I am a hair stylist so I've
been excitedly announcing that to people
but I had an encounter today where one
of my clients was less than thrilled
about my news and she was telling me how
we would have to basically untrain my
son from the patriarchy and how he was
going to be privileged and just born
that way and I feel like I I didn't know
what to say and I didn't really defend
him and I feel like maybe I should have
my husband said I did the right thing by
not making a big encounter with someone
who I'm trying to be professional with
but
um I wondered if you had any thoughts
about how to handle a situation like
that if it does come up in the future
thanks so much
uh I think your instinct is probably
more correct than your husband's but it
depends on how the woman said it
did the woman say oh you're having a boy
oh you know he's going to have that
patriarchy you're gonna have to train
him to be a good little feminist hehe
and then you say oh he he I think he'll
be just fine don't worry and you can all
be laughing if the woman was more
serious about it if the woman actually
said aha boy and I know people like this
oh boy it's too bad you name it girl
boys are terrible oh you're gonna you're
gonna have a hard time you're gonna have
to train him I would tell her to leave
my shot this is your kid I mean your
kid's alive
right you're that's a real kid in there
it's not just an image of a kid it's not
just a fantasy of a kid it's a real kid
in there this is your real son
that's fighting words from this woman so
you know you'll have to use your
judgment in how how this woman really
means it but if she is really insulting
your son
you know I
I try to I try to keep it clean you know
I don't I don't I don't go Blue too
often but I probably would in that case
I'd probably have have a couple words
for that lady that were not happy
birthday and I at the very least tell
her to leave my shop
if she's jokey jokey then you can be
jokey jokey too but I would still be
firm about it say no my kid will be just
fine don't worry
and he's going to go I'm going to train
him in the patriarchy and then he's
going to grow up and he's going to put
feminists like you in their place
actually lady
see if she laughs at that next question
hi Mr Knowles thank you for being the
best DW commentator out there my
question for you is is it possible to be
anywhere
as a conservative and be an emotional
person because I look at guys like you
Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh Andrew claven and
Jordan Peterson and it seems like you
guys are thinkers you guys just have
these qualities more associated with
being a thinking person me I base a
majority of my decisions on my emotions
and I've noticed that the left likes to
do that all the time based every single
decision or opinion that they have based
on their emotions so is it possible to
be anywhere near the right and be an
emotional person or is the right just
reserved for the thinkers thank you for
taking the time to hear my question and
I can't wait to hear your answer thank
you
listen you clearly have excellent taste
in your choice of podcasts and hosts uh
but your
your question
raises another question
which is what do you mean by emotional
I consider myself very emotional I mean
that I'm not I'm not joking my wife
might disagree she might think of me as
a block of sort of stoic obsidian that
has no feeling whatsoever but I consider
myself very I'm moved emotionally very
easily by books by films by a butterfly
floating next to a flower okay I I
feel lots of things but I don't allow
myself to be blown away by my emotions
so I think a conservative has to be
emotional a conservative has to have a
sort of feeling with his fellow man
uh the left often doesn't though the
left allows themselves to be blown away
by their emotions they are they often
won't allow themselves to to actually
have compassion with their fellow man
they say that half of the people are
just awful evil terrible fascists right
I mean there's a great story recounted
in Whitaker Chambers book Witness
back when Chambers was a communist
before he left communism he was walking
with a fellow communist and a derelict
came up to him on the street and begged
for some pennies or for some food
and Whitaker Chambers gave him a couple
coins and the other communist turns to
me says you shouldn't have done that we
can't feel anything for them it dulls
the Revolutionary spirit
and that chamber has obviously felt a
natural kind of human
feeling right natural human compassion
but you have to bring your emotions into
line under your reason you have to bring
your your base passions and your unruly
emotions into line underneath your
rational will which mediates between the
appetite and the Divine will okay
otherwise you will be just blown away on
gusts of appetite and and passion and he
won't be able to get anything done
so really if you want to be a
conservative
if you want to be a sort of educated
person period you you should
heighten your feeling of emotion not
just to some narrow kind of childish uh
feeling of passion but to the whole host
of human emotions all the way up to you
know gazing up at the sky and and to you
know being moved in the way that men
have been moved for Millennia all the
way up to to longing for the love that
moves the sun and the other stars
and
you need to cultivate your reason and
your rational will to uh to direct those
desires into their proper place
next question
Michael good morning Braden here how you
doing
my question relates to Twitter do you
think Elon Musk should give Trump his
access back that's my first question
second question if he does give Trump
his access back do you think he should
do it before the midterms my argument is
no because
I don't want to try to mess anything up
curious your thoughts thanks obviously I
guess that voicemail bag came in last
week before before the midterm elections
uh
yes Elon should give Trump his Twitter
back it will be great it will be awesome
I don't care I'm not of the opinion that
Donald Trump he's ruining everything for
the Republican Party the Republicans are
ruining everything for the Republican
party this squishes and the losers and
the the morally vacuous spineless
jellyfish in Washington are ruining the
Republican Party Mitt Romney is ruining
the Republican Party take his Twitter
account away I don't want Mitt Romney to
have a Twitter account I want Trump to
have a Twitter account okay so yes he
obviously should get it back
he should get it back because when
Twitter took it away from him that was a
major assault on our political system
that was a billionaire in Silicon Valley
saying or really just the sort of Deputy
to a billionaire on Silicon Valley
saying that
she
ought to be able to control the Public
Square which in a self-governing
republic means control the political
order much more than the people
and the duly elected sitting president
of the United States so yeah he should
get his Twitter account back also it
will be super funny also Trump is much
better for the Republican party than 99
percent of Republicans next question
hi Michael my name's will like you I
Come From The Fabulous Democratic
People's Republic of New York and like
you I've gone from the edgy atheist in
my teen years to the path of Catholicism
now in my mid-20s this has brought up a
question though as a Catholic how do you
reconcile the current pope's views on
things like supporting same-sex marriage
and its apparent support of the Chinese
Communist party when he should be
holding up the views of his faith I'm
still new to my church so I don't want
to go and ask these kinds of questions
to anyone there because I feel like I'd
be the newcomer questioning things he
doesn't know anything about thanks for
your time love the show and God bless
you and everyone there at the daily wire
so thank you very much God bless you as
well and your intuition is correct you
would in this case be the newcomer who
doesn't know what he's talking about
because the Pope
certainly does not support gay marriage
I this Pope has made lots of confusing
statements
and I will be the first to ask questions
about those statements and I have many
doubts about things that he's said but
he has been crystal clear on gay
marriage in fact when he was Cardinal of
Buenos Aires uh Pope Francis then then
Cardinal bergolia said that gay marriage
is quote no mere political Lobby it is a
machination of the Father of Lies who
seeks to deceive and confuse the
children of God he was then asked later
on this was fairly recently actually
if uh Catholics if they obviously can't
have gay marriage because it does that
doesn't exist but uh can they have
blessing Ceremonies for homosexual
unions and the Vatican this is Pope
Francis said no because uh God cannot
bless sin God
blesses people who sin namely all of us
we all sin but God does not and cannot
bless sin itself so the pope has been
absolutely crystal crystal clear on that
as for what the pope has done with the
Chinese Communist Party
uh yeah it's unfortunate throughout the
history of the church the uh The
Sovereign pontiff has made certain deals
with different governments that one
hopes are in his View for the good of
the church and uh Pope Francis has done
all sorts of things in China that are
dismaying and worrying uh but I I
that that would be much more of a
political matter I think than something
on the you know
the faith in morals which was alluded to
in your first point that that that I see
why you got the impression that Pope
Francis is in favor of gay marriage or
something but uh that's just because the
newspapers lie you know because the
newspapers always lie so you you
definitely should not believe everything
you read in the papers okay uh let's get
to some written mailbag the old school
way from Jarrett hey Michael
my wife who I've been married to for
three years informed me her father has
been taking hormones and believes that
he is transgender for some time now we
have a 10 month old child and we don't
feel it'd be right to cut his grandpa
out of his life however we believe the
transgender movement is possibly the
biggest threat to youth in this world I
am so angry at the world's approach to
this situation as well as the people who
knew this was going on rather than
getting him help they described they
decided affirming was the best thing to
do I want so badly to get him help but
fear he's too stubborn and too far gone
to reason with any advice that you have
whether relating to how I approach
getting him help or handling this with
my own son and the possibility of having
a transgender grandparent I appreciate
the time thank you
awful position that you are in
you say that you think it would be wrong
to deprive your child of his grandfather
your your
child's grandfather is the one who's
just who is depriving the child of his
grandfather
because the grandfather is the one who
is renouncing his position as a
grandfather and pretending to be I don't
know a grandmother or something else
so it's your grandfather who's doing
this
because he's either mentally ill or
taken up in a social contagion of gender
ideology or both either way though I
would approach the relationship in the
same way you would with any other person
who is mentally ill which is you know
you try to get them help you should not
affirm this stuff the way you phrase it
you say you know it was decided that
they would affirm this no well I don't
know who they are and I don't know what
it was decided means but you should not
affirm this
your wife should not affirm this uh and
this would be very very confusing for
your child and so I would I would
proceed with great caution and I would
make it clear when you do see your
grandfather or whatever the child's
grandfather
I would make it clear that you know
grandpa has a mental illness and we need
to treat him with pity and compassion
but this is not right this is not right
this is not good and even that
I don't know exposing a child to that
kind of Madness that close could be very
detrimental to the child so I would
proceed with with great caution and I
wouldn't feel guilt about you making the
decision to deprive your your son or
daughter of of uh of a grandfather the
grandfather made that decision and the
family that enabled that made that
decision so I'd be very very cautious
all right let's see take take one more
from Brian greetings Nostradamus
my question could be addressed to any of
the daily wire hosts as I can imagine
all of you spend countless hours pouring
over the mainstream liberal media in
preparation for your shows how do you
spend so much time in mainstream liberal
media yet keep your sanity I feel
confident in my conservative beliefs yet
I don't want to trap myself in an
information Silo whenever I attempt to
watch liberal sources I find myself
becoming angry from the obvious lies how
would you recommend individuals like me
pursue both sides of political issues
thank you Brian
oh well I would do so from a position of
amusement and as a kind of
investigation and training you know one
great thing about reading a lot of
liberal press is that you learn the
tricks you learn how they do things you
know the most basic example would
probably be when Democrats have a
scandal
that's not how it's reported when
Republicans have a scandal the headline
is Republican has a scandal when
Democrats have a scandal the headline is
Republicans pounce on Democrat Scandal
and I don't think
as some people say that you should spend
equal time reading the conservative news
and the left-wing news I don't think
that's true at all why would you waste
so much of your time reading falsehood I
would read the true stuff and then I
would sprinkle in the liberal stuff I do
consume a decent amount of liberal media
that's my job but
I don't I don't I've never watched a
full episode of The View I watch little
clips of The View I've never watched a
full episode of CNN certainly not in the
last 20 years
but I'll watch little clips of it I'll
read you know a column or two I don't
read the New York Times every day I read
a column or two maybe so I would
sprinkle that in but surround yourself
with the truth you don't need to give
equal weight truth and falsehood that is
a lie and a great error of our Modern
Age that too many people on the right
have fallen into you don't you can you
can pick you can choose as Bill Buckley
pointed out very wisely at God and man
at Yale skepticism as utility only when
it leads to conviction you know the rest
of the show starts now
we have got a really important stuff
today this is fake headline Friday I
have been on an absolute tear Ben Davies
is so upset because I keep guessing the
fake headline I need your help to do it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]